[Música]
la guerra de Siria que nació en el marco
de la primavera árabe es un conflicto en
el que se involucraron varios actores
regionales y también internacionales en
nuestra sección en contexto repasamos
quienes siguen inmersos en esta guerra
el primero por supuesto el gobierno y el
ejército sirio que es liderado por el
presidente bachard que reprimió
violentamente las manifestaciones
ciudadanas que eran pacíficas luego vino
el estallido de esta guerra civil que lo
enfrentó a los Rebeldes sirios que son
conformados por diferentes grupos
ciudadanos también ex soldados que
buscaban la salida de alazad del poder
en medio del caos el autoproclamado
estado islámico apareció en escena
aprovechando toda esta guerra para
tratar de ganar terreno Y también
proclamar allí su califato que
posteriormente desapareció en esta
guerra también entran las milicias
kurdas que son el brazo armado de la
rama Siria del partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán de Turquía un
país que de Siria recibieron apoyo de
Estados Unidos inicialmente en su lucha
contra el autodenominado estado islámico
también está en este conflicto Rusia que
entró a esta guerra para proteger a
basar al azar Siria es un Aliado
histórico de Rusia y por esta misma
razón Irán y el grupo hezbolá se
involucraron también en este conflicto
para poder proteger sus intereses
geopolíticos y también sus intereses en
la región de medio oriente y proteger
por supuesto a su gran Aliado en la zona
el presidente bachara la Sad el actual
presidente de Siria por otro lado
tenemos a un jugador internacional muy
importante Estados Unidos que llegó a
este conflicto junto a una coalición de
60 países que buscaba contrarrestar la
presencia que tenía Rusia en este
conflicto y también provocar la salida
del presidente alasad en Alianza con las
milicias kurdas sin lograr ni sin tener
ningún tipo de éxito por eso se retiró y
dejó prácticamente a los cursos por su
cuenta otro actor importante es Turquía
que llegó conflicto debido a ese pasado
histórico que une a Turquía con Siria
ambos países fueron parte del imperio
otomano Turquía aprovechó este conflicto
para atacar a las milicias kurdas que
allí cuyo partido político es entendido
desde el gobierno de ankara como un
grupo terrorista por su parte Israel que
no se ha involucrado oficialmente en
este conflicto ha tenido presencia allí
y cómo lo ha hecho a través de
bombardeos de manera preventiva en el
territorio sirio para mitigar el avance
que tiene Irán ijesbolá que es
considerado por Israel como una amenaza
latente para su territorio Estos son
actores que siguen involucrados en mayor
o menor medida en este conflicto que
todavía pues Tal parece que no va a
llegar a ningún tipo de final